welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
the movie channel
so i told you last week in a very short
video i was on the holidays
that michael deluca and pam abdi who are
the uh the chairman of the motion
pictures for mgm and the motion picture
group president basically the two top
people for mgm uh motion pictures in
particular but they really are the top
two executives have resigned
but
they didn't really as much resign as um
get pushed out mike hopkins who is a big
executive for um amazon released a
statement not long afterwards saying
that basically their departure has paved
the way
for mgm to be merged and to become a
part of
amazon and amazon pictures amazon has
been making lots and lots of promises
they've been promising that there would
be no job losses
that there would be
um an element of independence stayed
within within mgm the mgm would be able
to continue to make its own um business
arrangements and continue to do projects
that it wants to do that basically
amazon were just going to act like a
parent company and they weren't going to
interfere too much with what mgm wanted
to do
so what's changed
well
mike hopkins in other statements this
week has blamed the pandemic of course
he's blamed the pandemic because why
wouldn't you
he said that in 2000 when this deal
began
they had no clue that we were about to
go through a pandemic that would
basically shut down the entire film
industry for 12 months
and that's a fair comment
none of us knew that was going to happen
obviously
um but it did
that has had a massive financial impact
however initially amazon and all of the
other streaming services actually did
very well out of the pandemic because we
weren't allowed to go out so we stayed
home we all
booked onto amazon prime
netflix netflix had a massive spike hbo
max in the us had a massive spike
all of these streaming services disney
plus for example really enjoyed the bump
from the fact that none of us are
allowed out well the growth of all of
these streaming services has slowed
significantly and actually amazon again
who had a massive spike in business
early on in the pandemic because we
weren't allowed to go shop so we bought
everything off amazon
stopped and the actual sale price and
their their share price has plummeted
quite significantly in the last few
months why did amazon buy mgm so if we
just quickly talk about that and then
i'm going to explain to you what is
actually going on here because amazon or
mgm
isn't quite the company i thought it was
in 1948 there was a big legal case in
the united states it's called the
paramount case all the big studios had
big chains of theaters those chains and
theaters that it owned either it owned
or through deals only showed their
movies so mgm had a series of these
theaters paramount did disney did and so
on and so on
the supreme court ordered that was
actually against fair play rules and
ordered them to separate
now this impacted mgm significantly
because actually one of the original
owners of mgm was a theater owner he
owned a lot of theaters over the next 10
years and 15 years as well television
became very popular and everyone started
watching tv instead and that really
ended the golden age of cinema so all of
the big studios had a decision to make
warner brothers actually expanded their
studio lots but they started making tv
shows and they started renting out
studio space
disney double down and they spent a lot
of their money on the disney um world
disneyland and created the brand through
that and they also um really heavily
invested into television
mgm didn't but they sold culver studios
and they sold a lot of it to real estate
they built a lot of housing and what was
left they sold to sony pictures uh in
68 i think it was sorry
um so so many pictures now own that
studio and it's still sony picture
studios today mgm took that money and
they started the casino change they
built the mgm grand and things like this
and they really invested heavily in that
area
when they then went on in the 80s to
have further financial problems
the studio part of mgm and the um resort
side of mgm got separators they're now
two completely different entities
mgm's um
resort is still owned by the company
that bought them back then mgm studios
and all of the related companies to that
is now owned by
amazon i always assumed amazon was
buying mgm because of the studios
because amazon's movies doesn't have its
own studios it produces movies through
partnerships with other studios it rents
space from warner brothers it rents
space at pinewood studios and things
like this
so i thought it was investing in a
studio company and you know an
old-fashioned studio that actually land
and actually somewhere to actually
produce films
it's not true they don't
amazon were always very clear that the
main reason they were buying mgm was for
the intellectual properties it's the
stuff mgm owns it's all the movies and
tv shows and things like this it owns
the intellectual rights to those
actual buildings mgmos is very limited
i always assumed at very least it owned
the double 007 stage studio at um
pinewood studios it doesn't it's only
owned it's only named the double 07
stage because traditionally that's where
the bond films are made and it was
actually built for the spy who loved me
it's one of europe's one of the world's
largest sound stages the mgm as an
entity is really virtual
there are no nuts and bolts there are no
buildings
it's people
basically and not many of them
so amazon when they bought mgm they were
just really buying the name they were
just buying the brand now early on they
promised that they were going to invest
in that brand
allow it to expand
stargate is relevant to that because
that was a big part of this three-point
plan that they wanted to run with
bond stargate and then started looking
at the intellectual properties and
hoping to bring back some of those
projects they did lie
or that's how the mgm employees now feel
anyway and the mgm employees and sources
that i speak to they feel like they've
been lighting
and they're now very worried that
actually mgm is an entity is purely
going to be absolved
um absorbed into amazon pictures that
their headquarters will be closed and so
and so on and that actually michael
deluca and pam abdi who were standing up
against this and were pushing back
against amazon and maybe trying to get
them to follow through some of the
promises were forced out because of this
new plan that they're blaming on the
pandemic mgm employees are furious
apparently michael deluca the motion
business is going to be walking and
moving over to warner brothers and
apparently he put feelers out to warner
brothers anything up to a year ago so
even when he was telling mgm employees
through memos not to worry he was
already looking for his way out and
already looking for his next job so he
saw this coming stargate
as i say it just means we're gonna have
to wait a bit longer
and
it really puts a threat whether the
vision of brad wright
is going to be allowed to continue
because that's been done with mgm
that's been planned for and all the work
has been done with mgm the people at the
mgm headquarters in beverly hills
those people may not be in jobs much
longer if you are a regular sidetracker
you'll know that i have a few sources to
work in and around mgm this all started
back when i first started sidetrek nine
months ago or i did a video that
actually turned out to be wrong
um but did get like nearly a hundred 000
views
somebody from mgm or actually a company
that works closely with mgm email me
saying this story's wrong told me why i
started a conversation with them
through that person i've now built up a
bit of a network of 12 people that
either work for mgm or work for
companies with mgm
this person originally introduced me to
them and has really helped me to get
stories to you and to understand what is
going on not just with mgm but with the
wider film industry and it's been
absolutely valuable
about an hour ago i got my first message
from one of those sources
basically saying
that amazon today or through mgm have
announced to anybody on short-term
contracts with mgm will not be having
their contracts renewed
a couple of people since then have
emailed me at least one person actually
talked to you regularly saying that
their contract has not been renewed and
they can put an immediate i think they
called it garden leave this is not
something i've ever come across myself i
don't work in the
public sector something i've always
public sector so this doesn't exist for
my industry
um
but basically saying that um their
contract isn't being renewed they've got
three months left on this contract
um but they're to leave now
and the last message i had off them just
a second i haven't had anything else off
there but the last message i had of them
was basically they had a security guard
stood on their shoulder and they were
clear in their desk
sounds very aggressive to me but
apparently this is quite common they
deal with sensitive information and
they're not to remove any of it
so they're going to be paid for the last
three months but they are leaving now
so this has come as not necessarily a
shock but it's making me sound these
people that i speak to have basically
become close to you know i've been
friendly with them i speak to them two
or three times a week to know that
they're having to go through this does
make me a little sad you know it breaks
my heart a little bit
the one person i've spoken to has
already said they knew this would come
in they've already had an offer from
another um big
studio and they're a creative i won't
say too much about them but they work in
the creative side of things and
apparently a lot of the people work on
the creative side of things doing um cgi
work or you know to get on the computers
and doing that business they're all on
reasonably short-term contracts because
pendle mgm are doing what projects are
going depends on how what skills they
need and that varies
so they don't put these people on
permanent contracts they tend to you
know the numbers go up and down
depending on what they're up to
so
he's been thinking about this for a
while he knew his contract probably
wouldn't be renewed so he's already had
an offer from another studio for me
that's great news because now i've got
an inside that studio
so
from a very completely selfish point of
view i go yay amazon i believe
had no intention of keeping mgm in its
current form
they were always going to get it
and just absorb it as i mean actually
one of the um amazon executives that's
what he called it he said we're going to
absorb mgm into amazon prime and amazon
studios
all they wanted was the ip all we wanted
was the rights to all these classic
movies and tv shows that mgm owns things
like rocky creed
um robocop i think um which is looking
like also might be looking for another
tv series as well or a movie
um things like 2001 space odyssey things
like forbidden planet things like
stargate and james bond that's all they
were interested in they wanted those
rights and now they've gone
and mgm will basically only be mgm in
name there will actually be no substance
there'll be no buildings there'll be no
p it'll just be in name
[Music]
you